- So wait, I have to
talk to you about this
because bonus songs on the
25th inspired by album.
Like this, you only got these songs...
There are songs that you had
recorded like in your life,
or not recorded, but like just played.
- Yeah.
- And there were fans
that actually recorded
because you didn't remember them.
- Yeah.
- And you actually found
a fan you would go to.
Is his name Allen?
- Yeah.
- This is the most incredible
story. Tell everybody.
- (laughs) So I've always been prolific,
but I've never written anything down.
And so I'd lose songs all the time.
And so it was the dawn of the internet.
So I'd get on there on some list serve.
I'd be like, "Does anybody
have a song called "Jessica"
that I sang once at a cafe in Toronto?"
And this guy would always write back
and go, "Yeah, I have that bootleg."
And, "Yes, I have that one"
and, "Yes, I have that one."
I was like, "Do you want a job?"
So I ended up hiring him.
He is worked for me since like '94-
- That's incredible!
- Or something like that. (laughs)